Họ hẳng tinh át về và xin anh được tìm buộc một số nơi sẩy ra và tối nhà hà lắm hình thư theo dự vương,
phải phát hức khẳng của xin tình hư tình, nơi diễn ra kể truy đại thường liên dành cho phòng viên chuyên chân nhà chắn.
Sự có sẩy ra khi tổn thủng nguy đôi nân trang đang tham dự sự kiện, bầu lượng mặt vụ phải ninh trong đường dơ khỏi khu vực án tròn.
Video làm chuyên trên mạnh só hội cho thấy tổn thủ chân được hộ tổn dơ xanh thấu,
ngày sau khi xuất hiện các tính lộn lời như là tức xong,
một thành viên độ các Mỹ sách nhận về A Peasong đã còn nụ xuống tại hiện trường.
Theo CNN, người lộ chính là mở về kết sản, trên thay trực thằng giám phát hử trình thông,
và nhánh trong kìm xuất tình hình. Nhi phạm được cho là đã bị bắn chết tại khu vực phản kết sản.
Dở trực Mỹ sách nhận tổn thủng tròn cộng các quan chức tất cả hông tham dự sự kiện,
đều đã ăn quan, hiện nguyên nguyên vụ việc đã được đường tra trong khi các bạn đến tại chỗ đồ Washington, được ăn cường.